what's going on guys welcome to the
third part of the shoiken money flow
tutorial video mini series uh where we
left off we actually calculated the
shocking mineflow now we actually want
to chart it up so
if you don't have the sample data code
the link is in the description for that
code
and down here is the actual code so just
do a nice highlight
and then copy it and paste it into an
empty script
so we'll just do that so once you've
pasted the code in there
uh scroll up to that empty slot there
and now go over to what we've been
coding and you want to just highlight
and copy and paste
the entire uh basically all the way down
the whole function and the actual
calling of the function
and paste that between here and then
you'll have to fix the indentation with
two tabs over
and now that we've got uh this
what we need to do is actually
give it some variables since it returns
two bits of data so we'll just say
cmf date
and cmf i don't know why
this is the y-axis there equals that and
then we want to just do
the most basic version of this would be
ax2.plot
and then cmf date minus starting point
colon
and then cmf y
minus starting point colon if you don't
know what the minus sp colon is you'll
have to watch
the uh charting tutorial series there um
and then we'll just color it white
so we'll save that and we'll run that
and just get the basic
um line
oh we're still plot printing all that
let's we'll i'll cancel that in a second
so there's your basic um jyk and money
flow here
now what we want to do is get that
oscillator line in there so we can draw
that so that's the next thing we want to
do
so the next thing we want to do is
actually maybe fill
in that data and the other thing i
noticed was
that was the the oscillator was a little
bit large
uh and we have to fix
right here in the part where it says
well y is less than the length of mfes
we accidentally for the volume range
this time we used the x variable
so it was always stuck on this last uh x
thing there
so this the x's here need to be changed
to y's and that will fix
that issue now to
add the filler what we want to use is a
fill between
um within matplotlib so what i'm going
to go ahead and do
now is
instead of plot use
fill underscore between
we can leave these the same and then
after that we'll remove the w for now um
and we'll say zero because that's the
oscillating line
and then where
uh equals and then we have to convert it
to a numpy array so we always say
numpy dot array and that will convert it
to an array
and we want to use uh this right here so
i'm going to just copy and paste cmf
date
uh like this
so where cmf date uh
or actually we want cmfy where cmfy
and then sp colon wherever that is
less than or equal to zero
we want um that to
fill between and then face color we're
gonna say that
equals uh or greater than or equal to
zero i think i said less than
g sorry there's like a dog like barking
in the background i don't know if y'all
can hear it and it's driving me nuts or
stopping me from thinking then alpha
equals
0.5
so that should be it let's check this
make sure everything gets closed off so
that where
clause uh let's see where
let's see i think the where clause is
gonna get closed often yeah
now let's check it again okay cool
so now we want to highlight this copy
that
and paste another one this time it's
going to be where
it is less than zero
less than zero and we're going to want
to make it
red okay so we'll save that we'll run it
and let's plot up apple again
oh i forgot to get rid of that stuff
again anyway uh so here's our oscillator
now with with
apple and the correct uh oscillations
there
yeah and so that is our uh shaken money
flow
uh as you can see as the money you know
is entering into it it goes up and
as money leaves down here it goes down
and then
and so on so that's how to do that
that's how to plot it up
hopefully you guys enjoyed it hopefully
you learned something new as always
thanks for watching thanks for the
support and subscriptions and until next
time